at the education secretary gavin
williams and joining us once again from
westminster
very good morning minister good morning
to you
it is i'm afraid to say another day and
had another u-turn from the department
for education what has led to this one
well what we've always said and i'm sure
you'll go back to when we first issued
the guidance back in may
as schools were returning uh welcoming
back those first set of pupils for the
first of june
we said this would be something that
would keep under constant review
then when we issued for further guidance
for full return of schools
back in early july again we emphasized
the importance of keeping this area
under review
and actually having had the opportunity
as we saw the
world health organization put out the
details of
their their thoughts on this one of the
key areas that they recommended in areas
of
high transmission that there is maybe
some worth of wearing face masks
in those areas of high transmission in
education settings
now we're very fortunate as you're aware
and you've reported on repeatedly
actually right across the country we're
seeing that
the level of covert transmission fall
dramatically
so many parts of the country are
increasingly safe but there
are some areas of a country where we've
had to do local lockdowns
and we think that it is right in those
few areas where we've had to do local
lockdowns
that it is right that secondary schools
in communal areas that youngsters
do wear face coverings only in those
secondary schools in those local
lockdown areas
and of course we were listening to the
who advice on that
yeah the the w the world health
organization advice changed on saturday
we spoke to jenny harris the deputy
chief medical officer
on the program on monday and asked her
directly about it why haven't we changed
she said the following if you look at
the world health organization it's a
consensus statement
still because the evidence is not strong
it also identifies poor compliance
doesn't recommend covering should be
worn when playing she carried on
that was what the deputy chief medical
officer was saying on monday so again
i'll ask
what has changed what is the evidence
that you are relying on we always hear
from you that you follow the signs
specifically what is the evidence that
this is something that needed to be
brought in because you know you've had
four days
to come up with this uh but we always
follow and listen to the best scientific
medical advice and that's why we're not
recommending that face covering should
be mandatory
uh right across the country in all
schools because uh
the best scientific and medical advice
says that that isn't necessary
that was the deputy chief medical
officer who has access to the same level
of information and possibly one would
assume
uh given our academic background with a
greater deal of comprehension than you
and she was saying
on monday that this was not something
that we needed to bring in
so i ask again what has changed because
to be honest with you once again
it looks like you've been bumped into
this by the scottish government as with
exam results
well as as as you highlighted what uh
jenny did sort of highlight the fact
that we shouldn't be bringing
uh mandatory face coverings in uh
communal areas
right across the country into every
secondary school
and that's not what we're doing but we
are recognizing the fact that there are
certain areas of a country where there's
a
high instance of uh or higher instance
of uh
coronavirus that we're taking in extra
precautionary measure
and when we do look at school return the
key thing the thing that has informed us
most of
all yes this is for scientific and
medical advice
and it's been on the basis of how we
ensure
that all schools are as safe as possible
there as good environment as possible in
order to welcome children back
and as we look towards next week and the
following week as more and more schools
come back
we want to create an environment that
has
safety at the absolute core of
everything that we do
because the safety pupils for safety for
those who work in schools
is absolutely critical for all of us uh
but i'm sorry the overwhelming number of
the lack
of factor in the department for
education making making decisions such
as these
it does seem to be something of a
problem i'll repeat on saturday
the who changed its advice on monday the
deputy chief medical officer said we
didn't have to change
anything as regards face mass you
repeated those comments monday afternoon
tuesday morning yesterday morning we had
the business secretary saying
on the program you know there's
absolutely no need for us to do this you
know the science is not there
you're not telling me it was a
coincidence that the scottish government
the northern irish government changed
their advice and then
then the government in westminster then
happens to do the same
well as as you um uh will have sort of
noted what we're recommending in terms
of mandating for wearing
face coverings in communal areas for
secondary schools
is only in a very very small number of
areas
in the country which are in local
lockdown and what we're doing is we
recognize that there are added concerns
in those communities about transmission
but we also recognize how important it
is for every child
to get back and as i'm sure you are sort
of
conscious of as well is it's important
that we get
all children back and all schools open
not just in those areas that
aren't in lockdown but also those
schools that are in areas where there is
lockdown
and making sure that we look at the
advice closely
act on uh that advice but making sure
that we do it in a sensible and
pragmatic way
that's why we're not mandating the
wearing of face coverings in
uh every school in the country we're not
mandating instead what we're doing is
we're passing responsibility for that
decision to head teachers who already
have so much on their plate in terms of
getting kids back into school catching
up on learning now we're asking them
to act as public health officials and
decide whether or not
face mass should be mandatory in their
school on what basis
are we asking them to do that well what
we've been consistent on in terms of our
advice is that
actually there isn't a need to be
wearing face masks in uh
in school can just change change their
mind
you're giving the responsibility to the
head teachers well we've always had a
system in this country where
there's a loss of uh devolved
responsibility for head teachers
and of course as you'll go around in the
middle of the mistake as you'll go
around
the whole school state in this country
uh every school
tends to be of a different shape and a
different size and we do recognize that
sort of head teachers will sometimes
need to show
an element of discretion that's why a
few weeks ago as i'm sure you also
picked up
is the fact that actually we made the
decision to make sure that
face coverings were mandatory on home to
school transport
because we felt that was the best route
in order to be able to sort of not only
to
minimize the spread of transmission
among pupils and
in the wider community but also making
sure that there's real confidence about
uh for children to be able to return to
school
these are all measures that at every
step
is about making sure there's the safety
of those young people
safety of those people who teach in
schools
and ensuring that actually all children
are welcomed back into school
in september that's our priority that's
our focus as a government it's a
national priority
indeed okay do you think that parents
pupils
teachers head teachers have faith in
your ability to see us through this mr
williamson
statistics out today showing that the
report out today upon the attainment gap
in our schools the latest data contained
in this report for
2019 since then the covet epidemic has
had a profound
impact on english education everything
we have learned so far
during the lockdown suggests the
response to the health christ crisis
will have a
particularly adverse impact on poor and
vulnerable children
disadvantaged kids at the end by the
time they take their gcses were before
the pandemic
18 months behind those from rather more
affluent
backgrounds isn't the simple truth of it
all mr williamson that the government
was
failing in terms of education before the
viral pandemic
well what you'd seen uh over the last 10
years you've been seeing a closing of
the attainment gap
that's why that's why today we're able
to sort of say that you know
from september you're going to be seeing
another 50 new free schools
that have been really driving academic
excellence often in some of the most
deprived areas of a country
and actually the focus in terms of
driving standards whether
it's the phonics revolution in terms of
giving
youngsters the best start in life all of
these actions are having a real
impact in terms of children's attainment
but you're right to say
is there more to do there is so much
more to do that's why the focus is
constantly there to
drive stanzas and push more uh push
further and what you've seen over the
last few months
uh not only have you seen a sort of a
you know
effectively a setting up of almost a
parallel education system with uh
you know the open national academy
bringing some of the
very best sorry i didn't mean to speak
across you sorry
but i didn't mean to be rude there no no
no i'm sorry and i'm sorry
similarly but the data says the gap
between rich and poor kids
has stopped closing the experts behind
this report say it will increase if we
want a demonstration
of the situation we're in at the moment
yesterday we saw the head of off paul
resigning a couple of days ago we saw
you being nominated for
mp of the year so so
every every bit of the government's
focus
it recognizes that we've got to get
children back into school
the best way for children to be able to
from the most disadvantaged backgrounds
to close ascertainment gap is to see
them back
into school that's why we're putting
that focus of
getting children back into school
in september what every single year
group we saw over 1.6 million children
back in school
before the summer holidays we want to
welcome all children
and that is the best way of closing the
attainment gap making sure that we have
children
from every background including and most
importantly from the most disadvantaged
background
back in the classroom sat in front of
their teachers who will inspire them and
give them the encouragement and the
support in order to achieve the very
best in themselves
that's why we're going to be getting
every child back into the classroom
in september that's our focus that's
what we're going to deliver on
gavin williamson good to see you thank
you thank you for having me cheers